[Musique]
je vois tout le monde faire ce test je
les ai aussi mais ne laissez jamais un
test définir votre beauté sous ses yeux
en fait je pouvais avoir confiance en ce
test je trouve plutôt fiable donc à vous
d'essayer voilà pour les potes vous me
l'avez demandé je vous montre mon
nouveau lave vaisselle les amis c'est
une tu ris sincèrement bon il est un peu
gros un peu large du cousin qu'il a eu
du mal à rentrer dans la maison mais
voilà on en est hyper content
sincèrement c'est en vidéo la tuque
ainsi
balayer ça
[Musique]
ait
été mal
[Musique]
alors ça y est 2022 c'est la guerre
pourquoi vous me direz parce que au
début tout allait bien c'était la parité
tout allait bien mais là par exemple
assez mes chaussures rangée de
chaussures super ça c'est les miennes
mais
là c'est les siennes et lassé des
siennes la lasser les siennes
là aussi et puis là et puis là et puis
là et puis là et puis là et puis là il a
alors 2022 la parité 1
c'est la guerre ce labeur
vous savez où se trouvent les bouteilles
de coca 3 litres si vous voulez
non ok et les fleuves où se trouvent les
plug
bon bah je me disais que j'ai
[Musique]
mais je suis sorti du lot est en train
de fumer parce que j'avais l'intention
de faire une petite vidéo pour remercier
les fans et puis après j'ai découvert
que le ps avait fait caca et quand même
l'ironie du sort c'est qu'elle a fait
quelques uns de vos mon disque de
diamant nombreux à faire des autotests
qu'ovide en ce moment et vous êtes
nombreux à pas savoir comment le faire
je vais vous montrer je prends jean
claude c'est un ami personnel qui reste
globalement béteille quand on rentre
l'écouvillon dans le nez il faut
impérativement que ce soit horizontale
le plancher des fosses nasales est
horizontale ne fait pas ça en remontant
vers le haut vous risquer d'abîmer ici
les filets olfactif et faire des dégâts
très importants
toujours toujours horizontalement c'est
pas la peine de se pencher la tête en
arrière on est droit et puis c'est pas
la peine non plus d'aller toucher le mur
derrière il faut aller assez profond
parce que si vous allez trop
superficiellement vous passez à côté du
virus mais vous l'enfoncer et vous
sentirez bien que vous allez derrière
touché l'arrière des fosses nasales ça
suffit c'est pas la peine de rester deux
heures et ensuite en fonction de votre
test vous fait différentes manipulations
avec le liquide et vous en mettez un
petit peu ici vous attendez un quart
d'heure s'il ya une seule barre c'est
que vous êtes négatif si en a deux c'est
vous